[Music]
what does it mean for you guys to be
here this is a huge week for Nashville
y'all are both big hockey fans obviously
and we've got the CM to the whole town
is right now it's crazy it's so good for
italic big fans to been taking them to
the game yeah yeah they're initiating
into ice hockey I suggested we leave
just a touch before the end the other
night because it was four to one and I
was like we will avoid the traffic and
Sunday our oldest thought it was like
adamant we must state at the very very
end so we did a couple hockey fans
amazing total yeah I love it
now Keith I have to say American Idol
officially coming back were you
surprised
May well no not really no I don't think
so because I think there was such a
strong audience for it and the final
season so it's it's a great thing to see
returning have you been approached about
coming back and and what do you think of
Katy Perry as a judge I think Katie's
gonna be great I think it's a lot of
moving parts but I'm glad it's coming
back yeah I am too and and Nicole it is
the year of Nicole we are so excited for
you how would you describe this past
year unbelievable
I'm like I can't believe it if someone
had told me that this year in my life
everything would come together like this
I would have gone no way so I just say
wow a big wow yeah what a lie season two
coming back are you excited are you
apprehend though we do not sure yet
we're not sure we're working on it no
did they say it was official I thought
restarted but maybe I know recently and
I really want it to we're working on
storylines and we've been working with
Leon Moriarty and David E Kelly and you
know but we've always said we only want
to do it if it can really warrant it
[Music]
you